if you want to be the best in the world
at anything you cannot follow
prescription if you want to be okay at
it then sure you can follow prescription
if you want to learn how to lose a pound
a month and get in decent shape then you
can follow a calorie counting worksheet
but if you want to be a shredded
bodybuilder or an Olympic Athlete you're
not going to get there through how-tos
you're going to have to create and Forge
your own path that is unique to you for
mechanical things how toos work but when
you're trying to operate at the top of a
field or when you're trying to do
something creative howto don't work
beyond the most extreme Basics I can't
watch Roger Federer play tennis and
swing the racket the same way nor will
any description from him on how to swing
the racket get me to swing it the right
way then we go to intellectual efforts
we start asking Warren Buffett while he
invest in the company and there he can
try and create a mental construct as to
how he thinks and how he invests in the
company but there are just as many
details to Warren Buffett's activities
when he decides what to invest in and
how he lives his life and how he thinks
as there to Roger Federer's body running
around a tennis court hitting a ball the
details are not transmissible they're
not copyable you can be inspired to try
it yourself but without that sincerity
that Obsession you won't get
there one of my other related tweets is
the only true test of intelligence is if
you get what you want out of life and
this one triggered a lot of people which
I love the tweets that actually trigger
a lot of people but they're undeniably
true which is intelligence is like this
abstract concept cep that we talk about
but the the real measure is did you get
what you wanted out of life and there's
a two parts in there it's not just one
part one part of course is were you able
to hack reality to get what you wanted
but the more important part is were you
smart enough to figure out what to want
in the first place and that means there
are many booby prizes that simply aren't
worth having and then there are others
that are out of your reach it's
ludicrous for me to desire wings or even
to travel into a rocket into outer space
because it's either low Roi effort or
it's achievable for me so what I want to
do is to figure out what it is that is
worth wanting and remember not wanting
something is as good as having it so if
you canot war in the first place that's
even better but the test of intelligence
here is getting what you want out of
life but also knowing what to
want reality is perfectly neutral it's
just a bunch of stuff happening it's
like it's like imagine imagine for a
moment you didn't exist and you were
just watching everything around you as a
movie but you didn't exist you were just
an observer and you but you were
watching your friends and family and
your co-workers go through this movie
you wouldn't care about anything this is
all just lights and sounds and colors
interpretation meaning is is assigned by
The Observer it's not inherent in the
medium so uh it's up to you to make
things exciting I originally did not
find life exciting that was my fault
because I had a bad philosophy about
life and then over time I realized
actually I only have this one life so I
got to find meaning in it I got to find
excitement in it otherwise I'm just
going to go through a miserable life and
then as I started accepting that I also
started noticing thanks to meditation
and and other you know learnings the
inherent Beauty in everything you can
watch a smoke Trail come out of a a cup
of tea and or you can watch dust you
know dust particles dancing in a Sunbeam
and it's as beautiful as anything humans
have ever designed you've just lost
track of it you can ponder you know the
vastness of the universe or or the
minute microbial you know gut bacteria
that live inside of you in their own
little civilization and it's just
completely fascinating it's just we've
blocked all these things out we've lost
all this perspective um so I mean it's
your choice whether it be optimistic or
pessimistic it's your choice whether to
be grateful or resentful uh it's your
choice whether to be truthful or
dishonest it's your choice how you want
to live your life and at some point you
just decide like uh one of my friends uh
Charlie noes he had this great tweet
where he said at the end of the day you
have to believe that either everything
is a miracle or nothing is and that's
your choice like and I choose to believe
everything is miraculous not necessarily
in the sense that there's some white
bearded dude in the sky who made
everything up but it is pretty freaking
amazing isn't it when you when you kind
of contemplate how big the universe is
how unlikely you are how complex of a
machine you are how many things that you
have around you and inside you that you
just take for granted it's mind-blowing
Beyond Comprehension not all of human
civilizations sitting down with pencil
and paper couldn't redesign even one
tree or one person so we're we're
already blessed with so much it's just
we lose perspective and I think most of
that loss of perspective comes from
being
oversocialized because crave stupid
things like Lamborghinis and
fame every exceptional person is built
in solitude because Society is
oversocialized uh we're just there's too
many voices in our head from TVs from
social media from Clubhouse here from me
talking to you there's just too much
noise even all the stuff that I'm saying
to you is noise because you're GNA go
back and you're gonna be like man that
guy had 20 great ideas how do I become
like him and that's completely the wrong
answer you're never going to be me but
you can be an amazing version of you you
can be the best you that the world can
possibly have ever seen and the way to
do that is to spend time by yourself
it's to only like like to really just
Embrace who you are 100% like and I
don't mean this in some cheesy like oh
you know you go girl you're so powerful
blah blah blah I don't mean it that way
I mean it in the sense that you have to
love yourself because you are correct
you are right there is absolutely
nothing wrong with you there is not a
hair on your head that is out of
place you are never going to be as
beautiful as you are now you are you
have everything you need to succeed it's
just you need to fully accept yourself
and you just need to go for whatever it
is that you want and you're not going to
figure that out until you become
comfortable spending time with just
yourself so whatever that takes whether
it's journaling whether it's meditation
whether it's long walks
self-isolation I don't think anyone is
possible of greatness without Solitude
and conversely I would say with solitude
it's impossible for you to fail now let
me leave you with some Reflections and
related quotes move Beyond prescriptions
Naval rant also said Escape competition
through authenticity no one can compete
with you on being you most of life is a
search for who and what needs you the
most find your why I think the most
important thing is to have a strong why
for whatever it is that you do because
it will get you through the most
difficult hardships as n say said he who
has a why to live for can bear almost
anyhow so if you get through the ups and
downs of the journey you will persevere
and ultimately be able to benefit from
the compounding nature of whatever it is
that you do Mark Manson boils it down to
one sentence what pain do you want in
your life what are you willing to
struggle for build yourself in solitude
Navarra recant tweeted the modern
struggle Lan individual summoning in
human willpower fasting meditating and
exercising up against armies of
scientists and staticians weaponizing
abundant food screens and Medicine into
junk food clickbait news Infinite porn
endless games and addictive drugs on a
similar note n grow the individual has
always had to struggle to keep from
being overwhelmed by the tribe if you
try it you will be lonely often and
sometimes frightened but no price is too
high to pay for the privilege of owning
yourself thank you thank you for
watching and if you like the ideas on
this video I think you will love my ATI
newsletter every Friday I send out a
Timeless nugget from an influential doer
in their own words with also a drawing
to make the Nugget more clear and
memorable I exclusively focus on
timelessness because according to Nasim
taleb's Lindy effect the longer an idea
has been relevant the longer it will
still be relevant and I only pick the
nuggets from influential doers simply
because in words of Steve Jobs the doers
are the major thinkers if you would like
to get all this every Friday just click
the link on the right side of the screen
to sign up for free you can also find it
in the video description
below